is he here or does he also
now let's give him a few more seconds
there it is
at some point i was playing the queen's
[ __ ] accepted
um quite a lot and i got
so much criticism for the opening i
thought it was kind of funny but
it's it's not
it's not the worst opening in the world
okay g6 is kind of unusual and once
against um
against sam shankland played g6 when he
put the visual on b3
and there it made absolutely no sense
uh it was just an awful move and it was
like losing
right out of the opening here it makes a
lot more sense
can i play g5
i mean not fg594 works
but if he just plays
we just take some plays for sure
i'll just play an id7 actually
i still have a feeling my position is
bad
if i could
okay now now i'm just g5 i have a
problem
let's go for g5 it looks like a slightly
better version now
i actually feel like i'm winning
something like take a form
f5 and f4
97 i can't even take with the queen man
don't i just win material
the real question is what tactics he'll
have after
f4 i assume he'll have something
like if he plays bishop c2 f4
he has moves like queen d3 with the
knight of six
he can also include knight d7 queen e7
then queen d3 but
f6 queen d3 knight f6
i have f4 i think it works out and i'll
take with the queen rather than the
bishop
i also have look at five in some cases
which
yeah i'd rather not
i think workouts have been solid kind of
why but
there was a lot of rook a lot of squares
as well could go to
and this one for some reason feels the
most stable
but it's actually going to be still very
difficult to play this position because
after i take on g3 he's going to take
with f1
and no matter how good the position is
it's going to become
very chaotic and difficult to play with
only one movement
okay so e5 i think is good just to keep
the position closed i think played d6
here
that mom actually happy to see i was
worried about d6
and now we're like oh can i go to c5
so i'm really waiting keeping his bishop
one g3 it's not going away anytime soon
and i don't see why i should help him
develop his attack by taking allowing
him to play fg3
now i actually kind of like that if he
plays b4 let's say i can go to b7
and my knight on d6 is a very solid
block hater so i i
yeah this might might even help
i mean he has queen c6 to stop that but
i don't think queen c6 is serious i
guess i'm i'm really happy
to get this in
um okay queen b3 maybe he'll play
between d3 allows
both e4 bishop f5
i think is fine followed by e4 i can
even play both
both moves
but why would i do that when i can
take on c2 by like rook c8 let's say
keep giving him decisions on where to
put his queen
and
how e4 okay looks fine
i should probably just play faster
because i assume this will get into a
time stream
and now queen of six i'm going to take
not one but the two of his pieces
and you see the knight on d6 is usefully
defending he has rookie f4 here
just take all his pieces now
yeah queen f2 i assume is winning rook
f2 pawn takes king of one rook c1
here
it was probably like made in one there
but i didn't see it
i'm just so we're 21 and 24.
i'm still really not good under time
pressure so
like once we get down to the last few
seconds
you